say again
i saw you flexing there on that take
there checking out yeah
you know no you know what happened i got
it cries are popping dude you're
crushing it
i gotta chill through the air
conditioner and it maybe flints up but
then i did look out i looked tried to
look at my tattoo which looks like [ __ ]
what is what does it say uh
this one this one's my name my
neighborhood on my arm it says
established in 1984 the year was born
stupid then i have scripture on my arm i
got a cross on my back i
look like i'm fighting in a [ __ ]
catholic crusade that doesn't exist yeah
he looks like robert de niro from cape
fear
yeah it's stupid he's got he's got like
[ __ ] scriptures all over
guys you guys are really big on your
neighborhoods
yeah we love the neighborhoods and we i
moved out of it immediately
and what's funny is is all it is is
nothing but horrific stories
about how shitty it was and what
happened but like everybody
i respect that yeah of the the uh
dysfunction
you guys are the the bay ridge boys now
we're the bay ridge boys yeah bridge
boys we made it even more local we got
into show business
to make it go even more local yeah like
what can we think of the most obscure
neighborhood to call ourselves
how about bay ridge brooklyn there you
go
bill did your friend who passed away did
he pass away from covid
no no that's it sucks to die during a
pandemic of something else that's not
the disease
it's like dying on 9 11 but you [ __ ]
weren't in the bill you got hit by a car
yeah yeah you don't you definitely don't
get the big press release
uh yeah no what it is is uh
without getting totally in the deal into
the deal it's just when uh
you know you start paying for your sins
i get it yeah i would suggest all of you
guys especially you giannis
i don't know you're sort of sitting
there sagging with that depressed look
on your face you got a lot of weight
a lot of weight between your ears i
would definitely go to a heart and
between his tits lately
i've gotten really fat recently bill
but um i am envious that the fact that
you guys got to be in show business
stay where you're from and um
you know still be able to go to the
teams you want to see but that's also
why new yorkers are such
meatheads is you guys never leave
and your perspective of the world is
like literally 20 blocks
yeah it's just like oh look at the
skyline look at that oh this is amazing
and then when you go elsewhere you act
like you're not uncomfortable you act
like it's just a piece of [ __ ] and
you're above it but the reality is
the second you guys get away from your
favorite place to buy your kicks and
your [ __ ] pizza
yeah you get horrifically uncomfortable
no i lost her okay i love going to la
i appreciate the sights now i roll
around in california i go
to the left over here we got a fire
that's on fire over there
so that whole block material giannis is
on fire
over here those mexicans right there
they're they're working over there
for less than a minimum wage over there
uh there's water being piped in from
another state over there this place
shouldn't be here
well none of you should be here we stole
the country giannis i know
what about new york you can't do that in
new york
i i hang out with you in new york
honestly like over here i got
shot this is where i saw a homeless guy
take a [ __ ]
and you might talk about illegal aliens
you don't have any of those in new york
that's why i got out of there and that's
why i'm living in new hampshire now
and country away from you man they're
taking my goddamn country you're not
gonna do it i got myself a gun i'm a gun
owner
come and get some anything comes up that
hill i'm shooting it
so yes you got such a [ __ ]
diarrhea of the mouth when you buy a gun
the last thing you do is go on the
podcast and let people know
that when they go in there at your house
that they need to be strapped to
yeah you just literally read your
playbook you dummy
but bill if you're depressed when you
come to do your show in connecticut
can you please meet up with us because
we are the cure for depression
we will [ __ ] take you on a ferry ride
we will [ __ ] set sail with you we'll
take you to some museums
we'll prance around get some [ __ ] ice
cream and get [ __ ] cute
and drink some smoothies and put a smile
on that sour face
i would do that in a second but giannis
i know you after the smoothie and the
sugar rush ends
i know as as chris says johnny long days
comes in
yeah now we call him johnny barton
because he keeps forgetting what he's
saying
one of my favorite clips i saw of your
show which i absolutely [ __ ] love i
think you guys are superstars man people
watching this you gotta check these guys
out
um i was watching uh this clip
some guy talking about kovit and he was
talking about the things
bad things that were happening and
giannis was just stoking the fires guy's
like
well you know there's gonna be hospital
beds filled there's gonna be blah blah
blah blah and then giannis just goes
riding in the streets and the guys like
rioting in the streets
and i literally i swipe past it it's
like i don't want to [ __ ] listen to
this [ __ ]
yeah yeah you know i hate that i'm right
so much
i avoid um
that train of thought because i know how
i'm wired and i'm paranoid and i i can't
listen to that [ __ ]
the same way like i avoid a lot of
discussions with parents when they they
get into that hysteria
like have you got your kid into a
private school yet you got to do this
are they doing puzzles if they're not
doing puzzles people are saying blah
blah
i just [ __ ] i just walk away so yeah
yeah same with me i don't go on the ride
i get the smoothie
i give i give chrissy the nod and then i
would slowly just back away
and i don't even give a [ __ ] what subway
line it was on and which way it was
going i'd go down those stairs and i
would get on it
and then just i would get away from you
yeah one of those things where it's like
yeah i [ __ ] feel like i'm trans today
what like like am i a bad person now if
i'm like hey today i feel trans and
that's what i want to go with
but then tomorrow i don't are you
shaming me by telling me
hey yesterday you wanted to be transit
today you don't like i just feel like
everything's a [ __ ] free-for-all now
on what you can and can't say it's like
yeah you know what today with bill burr
i wanted to go trans and that's i felt
right and maybe tomorrow i won't
no listen no nobody's saying you can't
go trans i don't know i don't know where
that came from
well all right i'm gonna go cut my dick
off
yeah stop with all the [ __ ] old
country horseshit
you you were 100 of this country you're
out of this soil
that that's that's what you are i am i
am
i yeah i am you're searching for an
identity and i can tell you right now
you don't get that fat eating greek food
[Laughter]
you are eating american poison that is
what you are eating
yeah i gotta get my tea man you got you
got maybe
a d cup going there yeah coming to this
stage
like gentlemen and i'm telling them it's
gonna get
it's it i could go one of two ways when
the baby's born either something will
kick in
his genetic coding will kick in and say
i gotta lose the weight for this baby
and do this and that or
it's just he's gonna be so exhausted
especially those first couple years
that i mean we get into a real i mean
i'm talking about a 400 pound
situation where i'm just gonna [ __ ]
slap bacon off his tits
on the patreon all day yeah
yeah i've got really has the potential
to become a big boy you see him he's
he's one of those
in shape guys but you can also see you
can see the fatty within
i'm going breakfast club on you now yeah
i mean
ask verzi how i eat he actually says
he's actually
cannot believe that i have not blown out
fully by the way i eat
he's actually said that i sometimes put
on displays that rival
like bobby kelly displays of eating
there you go there you go all right guys
thank you so much i hope to see you soon
when this [ __ ] is over we really hope
you enjoyed that episode whatever it was
about this is just a stock thing that
we're taping on to every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild